bonsoir et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro de kiosques qu'est ce que votre
magazine culturel sur saint quentin en
yvelines et ses environs tout de suite
le sommaire de ce mercredi 18 novembre
johnny montreuil artiste compositeur
interprète au répertoire rock et
manouche je viens partager avec nous son
retour de résidence artistique à la
batterie de pluie en cours pour un
concert samedi soir à 20h30
nous reviendrons sur le bilan de la
première édition du festival et
saint-quentin festival de documentaires
inauguré jeudi dernier bilan allégé car
toute la programmation n'a pu être tenu
en raison des terribles événements de
vendredi dernier nous vous avions
annoncé la venue dif radia danseur
chorégraphe et artiste associé au prisme
d'elancourt celui ci ne pourra être
présent une de ses danseuses s'est
blessé cet après midi pendant les
répétitions
la à la représentation sera
malheureusement annulé une réunion avec
les partenaires a dû se tenir en urgence
nous nous excusons pour cet événement
indépendant de notre volonté nous
démarrons donc cette émission avec le
bilan du festival jeudi dernier à l'ugc
skywest en avant-première à la diffusion
de demain film co réalisé par mélanie
laurent et ses rayons un bel événement
qui a rassemblé 4 170 personnes
cependant la programmation comme je vous
le disais n'a pu être maintenu dans son
intégralité en raison des tragiques
attentats de vendredi dernier conduisant
à la fermeture des salles de spectacles
retour sur le bilan de ce festival
images de camille lambert et william l
jeudi dernier et est inaugurée à l'ugc
skywest le festival saint quentin
festival de documentaires autour de la
thématique de l'environnement pour cette
première édition
projet initié par tv fil 78 ce festival
a pour vocation de rassembler les
acteurs locaux et de proposer un autre
regard sur le monde
rassemblés sur un moment là en
l'occurrence sur quatre jours des
établissements très différents avec
lequel on travaille avec lesquels on
travaille pas forcément
fx est aussi un acteur du territoire fo
est bien de travail que les autres sur
ce moment l'important c'est de fédérer
autour d'un événement culturel au sens
large que ce soit des salles de chine et
de ses mâts de spectacle ou d'autres
lieux comme les universités pour pouvoir
créer un événement qui est un peu
différent de ce qu'on peut vivre dans un
cinéma classique et de pouvoir faire
participer à un public dans différents
lieux du territoire
initialement prévu du 12 au 15 novembre
le festival devait proposer outre les
projections de documentaires des débats
expositions ainsi que des ateliers
pratiques ouverts au public comme ici au
ciné cette d'elancourt avec un atelier
pour réaliser un plan séquence à la
façon des frères lumière j'ai fini le
client s'est pas bougé
qu'est ce que j'ai appris voilà c'était
pour tourner un petit à petit et c'est
donc à la façon des frères lumière donc
la façon de se positionner pour déjà ne
pas bouger et puis essayer de trouver un
cadre intéressant avec des flux de
personnages opération réussie
ce nouveau festival a su fédérer le
public c'est toujours bien quand il y
avait cinq secret ça fait bouger les
limites de
les regards je trouvais que ce festival
du film comme un devoir
post2 belle intégration sur la réalité
du monde d'aujourd'hui
c'est l'occasion demande de penser à
autre chose est de voir des films qui
peuvent changer des choses c'est bien
que ça fait ici pour ça change que ce
soit en danse et apparaît cependant
toute la programmation n'a pu être
obtenue en raison des attentats
tragiques de vendredi la cérémonie de
remise des prix a été reporté mais en
attendant les prix décernés sont les
suivants prix tv fil pour cobra gipsy
prix des cinémas à prisonniers
volontaires de la banquise et enfin le
prix 3 il s revient à amou beya retour
sur le plateau du kiosque votre émission
culturelle avec johnny montreuil auteur
compositeur interprète que l'on pourra
retrouver sur la scène de la batterie
samedi soir à guyancourt alors denis
montreuil avant de vous présenter
je propose que l'on fasse place à la
musique avec un extrait live sont
toujours nous complétons jack et pour
finir tes chacun chante pour exister
c'est déjà pas mal
salvatore les retards ses parois du trou
l'ancien qui rentre dans la coach
bélanger amapienne au guide de sucre
d'orge jacent qui descendent qui tient
la voix qui joue qui balancent leurs
franquiste pour de xuzhou chaud chaud
chaud match de ben et moi j'entends
genest se racontant ce n était pas ma
route seront toujours plus joli ce
nouveau art et horreur dans ses mélodies
aux accents percolateur temps on vient
de vous voir à la contrebasse en train
de santé que vous pourriez nous
expliquer cet univers un peu vintage aux
accents manouches un peu rock ça vient
d'eux ça vient d'une passion départ pour
toujours présente entre autres parce
qu'il ya docid hauteur de ton à doute
goûts musicaux qui se mélangent sans
savoir trop pourquoi
le point de départ c'est vraiment la
rencontre monde de johnny cash avec
doudoune johnny remontera est d'ailleurs
à montreuil donc l'adaptation de
quelques titres de johnny cash pour avec
un certain pouvoir y avait un ton oui
effectivement par rapport à la ville et
montreuil un ton très peu caustique et
sur le sur la réalité délurée pseudo
presque délinquante de du personnage
mais ça fait référence vraiment à des
titres de johnny cash et la rencontre
donc moi la contre basse et au chant
donc avec un style assez country
rock'n'roll hillbilly et la rencontre
avec un violoniste tzigane et donc
forcément cet univers fait référence à
montreuil directement avec toute la
culture tzigane manouche kia c'est pas
du swing manouche qu'on fait c'est ça
une grosse à une grosse connotation rock
and roll mais c'est vrai qu au niveau
des arrangements au départ l'intérêt et
le contre-pied moi qui m'intéressait
c'était de ne pas amener des gros riffs
de rock'n'roll comme tous ces groupes un
peu vintage rock'n roll qui reproduisent
un peu à l'identique ce qui se passait
commande et qui sont même quasiment
déguisé moi mon sens l'idée c'était
d'amener ce contre-pied là avec toute la
toute la culture toute la culture
manouche tzigane qui peut y avoir
derrière le jeu de geronimo violon et
ensuite autour de ça on a on a monté un
groupe donc à qu'un batteur et
guitariste électrique qui vient aussi de
7 qui vient du manouche si donc à cette
date là mais c'est pas du swing manouche
non plus et puis qui va mieux
surf rock and roll qui karl grosse
passion pour la musique des balkans
aussi ses nerfs trouvais qu avec la
violoniste et un harmoniciste qui
climatique de l'autre oeil qui est
artiste dessinateur des travaux
l'harmoniciste si donc il ya un moment
dans la touche menu ce qu'on attribue
aussi donc avec tous ses composantes là
on a on a réussi à avec deux années de
travail en travaillant disque et le live
à avoir notre patte à nous celle que
vous pouvez voir avec johnny montreuil
en live et qu'est ce qui n'aurait du
coup cet univers c'est vraiment la rue
la vie le côté décalé de la société
c'est notre vie notre vie simple et
égaie à montreuil avec plein de plein de
médecins comme un esprit très village
même si c'est une très grande ville fait
partie des plus grosses villes de france
et quand même un esprit très village
dans cette ville avec plein de café avec
plein bois énormément d'artistes dans
cette ville qui se fréquente qui se
côtoient ceux des rockers des rappeurs
des graffeurs des danseurs des
photographes et vidéastes c est tout ça
forcément dans les cafés oui puisque on
se rencontre on a envie de faire des
choses spontanément ensemble puisque on
se fréquente ya pas que ça aussi à tous
nos amis tous nos potes qui font autre
chose
on joue à la batterie de 21 et samedi
prochains la veille on organise une
grosse soirée à montreuil avec la sortie
d'un disque dur pour des ânes ou avec un
dj qui vient qui m'aident à lire à côté
très populaire dans ce camp de véhicules
et dans la manière d'être proche des
gens possible dans les textes
et puis dans la démarche et la démarche
elle est de huy d'aller jouer là où
c'est possible tout le temps alors
maintenant on est aussi avec la sortie
du disque et grâce à ce qui s'est mis en
place avec olivier moulin les facéties
de l'us ham on a réussi à aller un peu
on doit sortir des murs de montreuil m
dès le début mais voilà à jouer sur 7
sur ce tableau là parce qu'on a un
groupe de musique s'adresse pas qu'on
partager sa musique
oui voilà et pas qu'avec ans et habitant
de montreuil à caen mais en société avec
le haut mettant tout le monde sur le
même piédestal musiciens public
tout le monde essaie de baisser de deux
véhicules et ça en concert qu'on est
pour un concert aussi dans toutes les
vidéos qu'on essaie de tourner alors
comprendre explorer votre univers c'est
un peu ce bouillon cette effervescence
de la rue culturel de la société mais
vous devez quand même avoir des
références musicales majeures non je
parlais de johnny cash départ chacun on
a des références moi les miennes sont
dans l'écriture et dans les textes
viennent beaucoup de renault de brassens
de mais aussi beaucoup de littérature
américaine que j'ai pu lire une écriture
assez direct je pense que c'est un
mélange de plein de choses ces prêts en
lisant jacques prévert aussi au début
j'ai eu un peu le dire des poètes en
prose sans en faire sans que ce soit
très
je trouve ça m'a touché directement
parce que c'est une écriture assez
simple sans forcément qu'il y ait des
verts ou qui accessible à tout le monde
c'est quelque chose qui revient
d'ailleurs lorsqu'on lit la presse à
votre sujet il ya un mot qui revient à
chaque fois on parle d'une réalité d'une
justesse dans les textes
après tout mieux c'est c'est juste moi
j'essaie juste de décrire des au départ
c'est des textes que j'écris qui sont
des chansons des choses assez simples
avec des petites ritournelles essayé de
lui de parler de parler d'un quotidien
parler de notre quotidien se faire
vraiment référence à la banlieue à notre
banlieue qui est très métissée très
mélangées mais avec toujours ces vieux
si tu faisais quand j'étais petit ou pas
qui m'a intrigué un peu ces genres c'est
du rockeur qui traînent par là qu'ils
sont qu'ils font encore partie du
paysage
mais pour le coup le concernant à me
concernant qui sont à 300 à 360 degrés
sur ce qui se passe dans le monde et en
banlieue puis on a la chance d'avoir
tout lé enfin pas tout mais énormément
de communautés qui se côtoient qui se
mélangent qui se fréquente qui vivent
ensemble bien agréablement avec le
respect des différences de chacun et
donc voilà m ça avec notre plume comme
on peut et se fond de rock'n'roll pièces
et ça c'est ce que vous disiez un peu
caustique
oui moi je sais pas forcément tout le
temps guest et mais en tout cas il ya
toujours un toujours un petit décalage
qui fait que c'est pas on se compose
sérieux dont ceux qu'on peut raconter
sous forme d'association justement dans
ce décalage ou pas nécessairement
nécessairement c'est à dire que pour moi
la manière de dénonce rien il ya un
système qui en place et un nom prend
part ou part il ya des gens de ce qu'ils
font partie de ce système là qui sont
pas nécessairement intéressés forcément
parce qu'on fait mais on revendique pas
le fait de faire quelque chose
complètement parallèle c'est juste que
par la force des choses on a envie de
jouer on a besoin de jouer on fait tout
ce que de la musique on vit que de la
musique
donc on cherche aussi des lieux pour
pouvoir jouer pour pouvoir s'exprimer
pouvoir exprimer notre envie de tout
sans aucun forcément le message c'est
juste sortira elle se détendre et faire
la fête oublier qu'il ya un travail
demain qui est pas forcément gay pour
tout le monde et c'est un c'est ça c'est
ça la pluie on est libre on est libre de
faire ce qu'on veut et où on veut et on
a la chance en plus de ça 2 rencontrer
des gens qui travaillent sur des réseaux
sur l'île de france andorre
l'ile-de-france aussi et qui ont vite vu
qu'ils ont envie de voir notre musique
d' écouter notre musique l'a proposé un
public comme ça c'est intéressant parce
qu'on est on arrive à toucher ces
personnes là qui qui nous met en valeur
en suisse notamment on a été déjà
plusieurs fois et et voilà après une
forme un peu de boulot autour du groupe
mais on reste quand même dans une dans
une forme nous pour nous en tout cas d'
aventure une aventure avec les cinq
personnes qui forment le groupe on est
avec toutes nos différences aussi mais
il ya quelque chose de très très
palpitant dans la dans l'avancement du
groupe qui se ressent je pense sur scène
parce qu'on est vraiment à chaque fois
content de jouer ensemble et puis où le
soir voilà c'est ça l'idée quoi c'est où
qu'on soit on n'est pas dans une
démarche de faut jouer là comme ça de
cette manière là on a un set qui peut
s'adapter selon les contextes 6,2 par
rapport à ce qu'on veut raconter on a
des morceaux beaucoup plus calme des
morceaux beaucoup plus énergique sur sur
ce que vous verrez la batterie vous
aurez un vrai cette de johnny montreuil
sur scène
donc ça mais vous êtes donc à la
batterie salle de concert est ce que ce
sont les lieux que vous privilégié pour
faire de la musique vous devez tourner
en festival est-ce que vous jouez dans
la rue aussi dans la rue pas forcément
parce qu'on est
oui il faut qu'il faut de l'électricité
ce que dit qu'à une batterie feu qui
rappellent des amplis un disco une voix
on a fait on a joué après ça nous arrive
d'arriver comme ça sauvagement entre
guillemets dans un café branché sorti un
instrument acoustique dans la rue n'a
pas une démarche de musique de rue c'est
différent mais on est des mario musique
populaire donc le jouer dans n'importe
quel contexte
après jouer dans un contexte comme la
batterie ça fait partie des salles de
spectacle ont sur l'île de france qui
sont qui sont dans lesquelles c'est très
chouette de jouer dans un rapport aux
conditions par rapport à la jauge par
rapport à la manière de mettre en valeur
notre musique d'un point de vue
technique on va dire c'est très agréable
pour nous au niveau du public
on verra mais on a rarement été déçus et
on en a je pense qu'on a c'est sans
prétention on a rarement déçu le public
voilà est-ce que cet esprit de liberté
ça celui aussi qu'on peut retrouver
parce que vous avez est ce que votre
dernier album qui est paru en mars
dernier alors corrigez moi si je me
trompe au niveau de l' accent narvalo
situe au rocker c'est ça est ce que vous
avez réussi justement à transmettre ce
même esprit est ce que ses fidèles à
votre groupe oi oi oi dont ce qu'on a
enregistrés dont ce qu'on joue
maintenant sur scène en défendant ce
disque là s'il ya plein de gens qui sont
contre ou v l'aspect justement 504
nardin allô allô c'est une expression de
à montreuil ailleurs mais qui est très
surpris par tout le monde à montreuil
c'est drôle mais alors ça c'est une
expression qui est du manouche
mais en tout cas lorsqu'on dans ce qu'on
fait après sur scène actuellement je
pense pas qu'on soit détournée ça au
contraire ça nous donne d'autres envies
des idées des nouveaux morceaux qui vont
dans cette veine là on retrouve avec ce
premier disque un peu vraiment une ligne
de ce qu'on veut apporter un peu sont
écartés y revenir mais là quelque chose
quelque chose qu'on défend dans la
manière de faire une musique là c'est
libre sans forcément entrer c'est vrai
alors on peut dire que c'est la chanson
française ça me dérange pas du tout
venir avec ma contrebasse chanter de la
chanson française sur scène à 5 c'est ça
va à mon sens ça va plus loin que ça
parce qu'il ya des influences qui
viennent qui viennent se mêler à juste
quelque chose de juste guitare sèche
voie même si la chanson française c'est
pas que ça mais c'est vrai qu'il ya une
énergie rock une énergie deegan
l'énergie blues une chacun ramène sa
sauce là dedans et voilà on cherche pas
à créer un nouveau style ou quoi mais
c'est vrai que bon voilà c'est il ya
quelque chose de chacun peut se
retrouver comme il veut où il veut ou
pas et c'est pas grave donc continuer
avec la même avec la même la même voilà
la même
là même qui était là même le mais ce
prix libertaire de faire cette musique
qui nous plaît avec on raconte en
écrivant des textes qu'on veut sans
qu'ils aient qui que ce soit qui est de
nous dire faut faire comme s'il faut
faire comme ça faut rentrer dans cette
case là dans cette case là
alors effectivement c'est plus compliqué
à développer un projet comme celui-là
mais beaucoup plus beaucoup plus riches
et puis beaucoup plus exaltant je pense
que de suivre faire un projet produit
entre guillemets qui va plaire à telle
ou telle personne pour pouvoir rentrer
dedans par du travail de concert etc
derrière bon c'est plus long mais voilà
ça grâce à vous grâce à d'autres gens il
ya des gens qui est des personnes qui
parlent de notre projet qui parle de ce
qu'on fait et puis on pis la suite nous
dira de quoi elle est faite en tout cas
nous on sait que si on a envie de
continuer à faire la musique on
continuera toujours à faire de la
musique
alors johnny montreuil on pourra donc
apprécier cet esprit et le travail de
votre résidence vu que c'est un retour
sur un retour de résidents sur scène
samedi soir à la batterie à partir de
20h30
johnny montreuil merci d'avoir été en
plateau avec nous on continue en musique
avec la rencontre d'une artiste montante
jeudi dernier à la batterie également de
guyancourt proposé un concert blues et
rock de l'artiste irlandaise grigny 2
filles de 29 ans versée pendant
l'enfance par la collection country de
son père gruny de fille apprend la
guitare avec ses deux soeurs sur des
reprises des rolling stones et 2
fleetwood mac
elle commence à écrire ses premiers
morceaux à l'université forme son
premier groupe avec lequel elle
enregistre son premier album
aujourd'hui elle nous présente son
troisième et nouvel album grey ni de
fées live et elle nous en parle
oui tu es sorti un album récemment un
album live qui a été enregistrée en
allemagne
on voulait absolument capter le son du
live car c'est un signe très différent
de celui enregistré en studio l'avant ça
y est le deuxième album best of time qui
est plutôt aimé principalement orienté
pop rock beaucoup de morceaux du live
sont issus de cet album est le nouvel
album live
vraiment mélanger pour le premier le
second album mais avec un super sondages
wen
c'est moi
non
scène
star
m
mais
partons maintenant à la galerie le
corbusier à trappes pour découvrir les
différentes façons de graver à la pointe
sèche ou en relief avec l'exposition
proposée par les ateliers graphiques de
lavilledieu jusqu'au 12 décembre
image de camille l'envers la trentaine
d'élèves des ateliers d'arts graphiques
de lavilledieu exposent leur travail l
agha lalai le corbusier à trappes
jusqu'au 12 décembre seront présentés
différents types de gravures dont les
eaux-fortes appelait encore taille douce
ou pointe sèche c'est à dire que sur une
plaque de métal soit on utilise une
pointe sèche un burin pour creuser le
dessin ou alors on utilise les acides
qui en réalité sont ici du père chlorure
de fer et qui ronge un petit peu la
plaque dans les endroits qui ne sont pas
protégés par du vernis ainsi dans les
endroits creusé par le burin ou les
acides lancre peut venir se déposer ce
type de gravure s'adresse aux supports
en cuivre métal ou plexiglas pour le
lino et le bois on parle de gravure en
relief une autre technique
là il s'agit de creuser avec des gouges
un dessin et tout ce qui a été creusée
ressortira en blanc sur le papier et le
relief va rester etc sera ancré à l'aide
de rouleaux et passera aussi sous une
presse avec le papier par dessus la
plaque qu'on appelle matrix
ces techniques sont employées pour
réaliser de multiples exemplaires
principe même de la gravure pour les
reproductions unique
on parlera d'estampés et on continue
notre tour d'horizon des différentes
expositions du secteur avec l'exposition
de thomas boiteux au conservatoire des
arts de montigny définit comme papier
peintre ou ingénieur en papier kraft se
place 6e plasticien questionne la
culture actuelle il reprend les codes
les symboles et matériaux du quotidien
pour nous proposer un travail riche et
diversifiée empreint de poésie
direction maintenant la mezzanine de
l'hôtel de ville de gland
en cours pour découvrir l'exposition de
clémentine de chabaneix artistes
céramique proposée jusqu'au 12 décembre
dans la thématique du monde merveilleux
clémentine de chabaneix présente ses
sculptures en céramique qui questionne
la nature le monde animal et végétal en
recourant aux masses qui a des
personnages systématiquement féminin
tout de suite les l'interview de catch
blonde au service du service action
culturelle de billancourt
autour de l'exposition démons
merveilleux nous avons voulu inclure
clémentine de chavannex car
effectivement elle a un travail qui se
réfère aux comptes
un travail merveilleux onirique et dans
l'exposition des mondes merveilleux nous
avons des petits personnages à tête
d'animaux et c'est ce que nous
souhaitions mettre en valeur et on
poursuit avec notre rubrique cinéma que
pensez-vous des films à l'affiché cette
semaine vos avis au micro de gérer
quesada le combat des femmes pour le
droit de vote en angleterre j'ai bien
aimé c'est un bon film sur ses
poursuivantes suprêmes allemands fin
c'est pas chez d'autres je suis assez
bon c'est un très bon film c'est bien
interprété c'est bien jouer c'est sûr la
justice et cet homme là est un très très
grand acteur français à mon sens une
très bonne interprétation de lucchini
bien ou sur le plan de la morale de
l'histoire c'est un très beau film qui
nous fait explorer le monde de la
justice et luchini est un génie absolu
comme d'habitude c'est aussi bien voir
enfin moi j'ai aimé 1 depuis le 1er
jusqu'au dernier et ça l'a même la même
valeur c'est bien très bien c'est très
bien c'est très très bien cette semaine
c gueye pineau du grenier à sel de
trappes qui nous donne son coup de coeur
de professionnels sur les nouveautés
bonjour cette semaine je savais pas trop
quoi présenter comme coup de coeur au
grenier à sel mais
et ça y est j'ai trouvé j'ai une petite
une petite envie pour le film s'appelle
notre petite soeur un film japonais du
réalisateur s'appelle corrida en 2013 il
avait eu le prix du jury à cannes pour
le film tel père tel fils là ce film là
notre petite soeur c'est l'histoire de
trois grandes soeurs qui vont à
l'enterrement de leur père qui les a
abandonnés il ya une quinzaine d'années
et à l'enterrement elles rencontrent
leurs leur demi-soeur qui a 14 ans et
qui maintenant est orpheline et les
trois grands de détroit grande soeur
décide de lui lui propose de venir
habiter avec elle dans la maison
familiale et la petite
les petites sous acceptent d'aller
habiter avec elle c'est un petit peu
c'est un petit peu étonnant parce que
quand même à l époque beaucoup beaucoup
de culpabilité elle est très mal à
l'aise parce que c'est un petit peu à
cause d'elle que la famille s'est séparé
et pourtant le film dure sur une année
entière
bout d'une année entière ses quatre
soeurs vous reconstruire une famille
c'est une famille
très belle c'est un film qui est très
très beau c'est un film tendre plein de
vie et
et donc je conseille très fortement il
faut savoir que ce film est adapté d'un
roman graphique donc on appelle ça en
vérité un banga
et qui est sorti en 2007 qu'on peut
retrouver aussi en france donc ce film
là vous retrouver sur cinéma grenier à
sel point com site internet
à bientôt et comme chaque semaine avant
de nous quitter je vous propose quelques
dates à noter dans vos agendas
jeudi soir 19 novembre à 20h30 je vous
donne rendez vous au scarabée de la
verrière avec éric toulis accompagné de
sa guitare virtuose pour un concert
humoristique avec un ensemble de
chansons loufoques dans le cadre de la
soirée cabaret bose les nouveaux
extraits
tu caramel
pour l'attaquer pour l'heure j'ai fait
le point dans chaque main
voir
samedi soir 21 novembre parts ont
profité du match d'impro organisé par la
troupe les épices l'équipe jeunes
talents de la compagnie déclic théâtre
au restaurant le petit paris à trappes
et enfin dimanche 22 novembre à 16
heures je vous emmène pour un concert
pour la sainte-cécile à l'église
saint-pierre de plaisir le choeur de ci
de là dirigée par sandrine conques
seeker pardon accompagnés à l'orgue par
gildas guillon interprétera mozart
vivaldi et hayden fin du kiosque pour
cette semaine l'émission à voir et à
revoir sur notre site internet je vous
souhaite une très bonne soirée